yeah hello welcome to this video playing
a spin dose yeah I'm mixing up my
openings a little bit here recently I'm
played very little off one year for but
why not in the odd game and this cannot
be so terrible ok seems that he knows
what he's doing this I think how they
play this nowadays not quite sure if I
mean I castled really early and not
entirely sure this is a great idea and
sometimes h4 ism is a very serious
option ok I'm kind of making things up
here the facts don't really know that
the the way Theory wants to wants to
play this position so he probably wants
to go d 6 + f5 here hmm ok maybe i'll
bring the night over to g3 to prevent
that or make it more difficult let's say
for him and i think this is a bit the
way I played this is a bit lame it's a
bit lame how
okay she doesn't want to develop an
altar be my guest this looks very slow
you know I can I mean I all the time
thought okay how can I get an F for to
get some active play and he basically
handed it to me I think I'm threatening
to take only five strategically this
would be quite terrible for him getting
him the yes the isolated pawns there
yeah Bishop chicks I think Bishop cheeks
is the most natural move yeah his queen
is not exactly having many squares yeah
even night at five it's not bad but i
wonder if i have something better
that's again later five is not it's not
a very aggressive I can also go Queenie
149 f5 they're definitely should lead to
a small advantage for wide okay let's do
that term it's a bit technical this
approach but it's not bad okay that move
I didn't even consider isn't that good
for my idol Queen g3 now here and these
six is hanging and I'm threatening
bishop age six things be five is also a
good movie 5 context Bishop takes and
this is awkward it's very awkward okay
um Bishop age six on the other hand what
is he doing there Queen f8 now queen of
eight maybe it's not not attractive but
maybe I'm still kind of playable okay
Bishop g5 and that's it so now I'm not
taking the rook here this is calling for
checkmate
black resigns Wow he managed to kill us
very good position quite quickly I'm not
sure that I mean the castle displays
cannot really be mistake but i think
they mostly delay this nowadays and go
d3 i played that attempt to quickly okay
so this is kind of normal looking and
now i think ii five is an alternative
quite often white cozy fire but ok i
just went for developer for development
you five yeah 92 andy sixx up to here
i'm completely agreeing with blacks play
but here i just expected which should be
seven castles we should be six and so on
and black should be ok i mean at least
okay i think i'd rather be black in this
position but night age for is just i
think just a bad move it loses lots of
time and I mean black has no development
and I'm castle to have the night on g3
and the thing is that this threat f take
c5 is pretty substantial so if he just
ignores everything here I mean this is
very very weak yeah I get in Bishop e3
and Queen to f2 and I'm putting lots of
pressure on c5 but this is close to
getting lost this pawn I know it doesn't
look good so he has to take I guess yeah
now I mean the comp gives rook takes
therefore that's probably also good yeah
this cannot be bad so yeah a couple of
interesting ideas this one as I said is
very technical I expected Bishop f5 here
thought that was the only move and I
thought that here I should be slightly
better because this pawn structure is
somewhat weak where Bishop is a bit
better him but well this is nothing
special nothing special but I didn't
want to spend lots of time for gap
chains and goes Queen f6 just loses I
think
check that loses the game the six is
hanging and twelve what what are you
doing here I could have played Bishop to
b5 already I didn't I didn't really see
that I was thinking Bishop age six but
he 5 is also pretty strong I mean what
exactly is he supposed to do if he takes
again still do this or this move is also
strong yeah queen of eight now yeah we
have six is strong for example and just
piling up fantastic position the bishop
is just so strong on that diagonal okay
so we had this song ever and here yeah i
know this is greater sure this is the
engine see a mate already it's just plus
15 it's just a matter of letting it
giving it a bit of time then it will
find the mate yap like resigned to be
empathetic this is this and the rook is
hanging yeah completely hanging that
same it's not even an exchange okay that
was fun thanks for watching